Michael it's been a few weeks now since
the fantastic qualification how do you
assess what you achieved in that
qualification period I think it's it's
probably something over the last few
weeks are probably reflect honor but
more than at the actual initial a
qualification obviously the the mood is
phenomenal the players to see to
experience what we did against Greece
and to be on the pack to see what amount
of the supporters is something obviously
it was memorable but I think now you
know I suppose it sinks and what we have
achieved and what this group of players
have achieved and it's really important
for me that the game in November that we
had a home game because after the Greece
game we were on a plane the next morning
to Finland we needed obviously a point
when the group would say we got but the
players on return from fennel and then
dispersed all different parts of the UK
they go back to the club so they never
really got maybe to appreciate what it
meant to everyone in Northern Ireland
and so the game against Latvia gave us
such that opportunity we were at home
for four or five days I think they fully
understood what it meant to everyone and
it was really important because now you
know I think it helps them refocus and
look at you know you know we're going to
the finals fantastic it's six months
away or seven months away at that point
in time but you know we go there with
obviously you know I mentioned to do
well and to continue the great work that
they've done do you sort of look at that
qualification table and see Northern
Ireland the top of thing how did that
happen yeah I I've looked out at nine
again to be honest you know I mean I've
reflected on the campaign and I think
that the biggest thing was was the you
know the growth and the team that I
think they were sayings of that anyway
in the last campy and although the
results didn't reflect up but there were
certainly sayings of that and and then
you know obviously seen it come to
fruition and that's Campion it was huge
for us and you know we started I when
the euro when the draw comes out you
know right let's finish in the top three
and then you win your first three games
and the mood change is a lot of betting
thing we could maybe get in the top two
here and many four games to go and
you're like a point behind Romania and
then you know after the I think the
Pharaohs game we were top at that point
in time and you think I feel when I'm
actually game it was no qualified and it
was just a journey for the player
the confidence you know the belief and
you know the most pleasing thing for me
was that having qualified obviously
after that the Greece scheme was that
the Refik lessening first of all they
enjoyed themselves which they're
entitled today and but they reform so
quickly to make sure that we we got what
we needed in Helsinki because they
really did want to run the group and it
was you know a fantastic achievement you
mentioned the word confidence and belief
but those must have been in very short
supply at the beginning of the
qualification process after what had
happened in the World Cup qualifying
group yeah I think we have it we have a
scenario or like you know in terms of I
always felt there was a bit of a
hangover from the Europe euro 2012
campaign you know I have ended badly and
I lost the last four games Home & Away
defeats to Estonia and I just felt that
like we probably carried out that period
when you come in as a new manager from
really January until the World Cup
qualifying campaign there's very little
motivation for the players even though
you're a new manager you know with three
games in that period one of them was in
June players weren't enthused about that
game and to you you want to try and
build something and you've got a group
of players that kind of you know their
focus is elsewhere and that was that was
very difficult that was probably the
most difficult period in the job if I'm
honest the biggest thing we did like off
the back the World Cup campaign as I say
you know you have a period then of maybe
about six to seven months before the
euros and actually even before the draw
and our first game I think we had a
friendly away in Turkey difficult game
we lost the game 1 nil but we did well
in the game I remember thinking we've
played well here tonight and Fighter
Eames first game I'm back in charge the
turkey it was a good compared at
Friendly's 25 30 thousand at the game
good atmosphere and then we we played
Cyprus away and we played pool it was
Nell Nell Pergium you came at that point
thing right how can we you know sort of
find Vicariate that's a little bit from
from where it was and a bit the biggest
thing for me was you know I took the
World Cup group and I showed the players
we had a meeting I showed the players
did group and you know I took Portugal
and Russia over I said can we win this
group with the 14 group and you know
they were pretty unanimous of course we
can win that
you know and then I showed them the ten
games and I says there's there was the
score in the games a seventy-five eighty
minutes I said look you know how many
games that shows you how close you were
to finishing third in the group although
we finished first you know we could
quite easily have finished third behind
Portugal Russia so I think that they
started to see that they started to
recognize that but we had to change the
mentality a little bit that we had to
you know we had to turn up and we had to
we had to find a way I went more than
anything and and the Hungary game did
that really you know because we went
behind and we played well in the game we
didn't really deserve to be behind they
scored off a corner and it was love but
unfortunate you know
Gareth McAuley it come off injured two
minutes later you know they scored for
corner guards hopes there are you know
probably our biggest you know center
pack in terms of defend and set pieces
so it was just circumstance think we've
done well here and things have gone
against us again here we're gonna lose
this game one no you know and then you
know Kyle hood played great in the game
you know came the party made the first
goal and and scored the winner and Niall
had come on as well now had a big big
impact in that game scoring the first
goal and obviously setting up the second
as well for Kyle's so and I just think
that that that was probably the turning
point for this group of players really
because they went we were losing that
game you know we would have almost there
would be an expectation to say we were
unlucky we played where we lost the game
when L well no actually we fought our
way back in the game of 20 minutes ago
and won the game 2-1 and then after that
you could just see it then start to you
know develop and grow as every game came
around where their senior players who
were starting to think is it worth my
while training up to play a game we hope
to convince some of the senior players
to carry no III didn't really to be
honest and that was one of the most
pleasing aspects of it you know people
always think that you know I when I took
the job I had you know Chris Baird at
the time was a little bit unsure you
know he wanted a little better time away
from international football which I gave
him and you know he came but he came
back and played and his first game was
my third game for example
ahran had
under an angel and you know I had sat
with iron and gone through this what we
wanted to do what we believed we could
do and at the time belly McKinley was
working with me who was working at
Fulham with iron as well so that
probably helped me in that that side of
things and Chris was at Fulham as well
but the preparation the team has been
fairly constant from day one on how
we've gone about things and we've just
seen obviously a better set of results
when we did do and they in the open and
Campion but no the most pleasing aspect
for me was that the players didn't I
think that they did believe that we were
going on the right direction and I
genuinely felt that they they felt that
as well you had conversations with
Stephen and you know I'm like we need to
do anything different how do we approach
this how can we change this and he you
know he was fairly you know front no
listen we just need to keep doing what
we're doing and then it will turn for us
or we will be more competitive certainly
and you know so it was great for me that
you know the likes of you know you know
your Gareth's Macaulay's you know your
aren't huge chris beard Chris Braun you
know that there was no issue with that
they were fully focused on the euros I
think they obviously saw the situation I
was able to sell off the point say let's
know you know there's an expand that
qualification process more teams at the
final this probably will be our best
chance and you know that they didn't
need any convincing just put into
perspective for for people who don't
know
the resources that you have got to draw
on compared to oh yeah we have a very we
have we have eleven of pull of players
there's no getting away from that and
listen you know I'm not you know I
suppose bleating about that for one of a
better word I think that like Northern
Ireland have always had a lemon at polo
players what we probably had in the past
was we had more players playing at a
higher level of the game I looked back
at the score that I played and pretty
much once we didn't have a huge pool of
players every player was a failure to a
Premier League club at that point in
time or or a championship club now we're
picking players from obviously league to
you know lead one SPL and Scotland which
you know isn't the strongest League for
on us you know and so you know we have I
think where we have seven players in the
Premier League
not clear jump re McNair the three lads
at West problem Stephen Davis California
and create Cathcart he's done extremely
well at Watford yeah I mean that's the
situation you face she have a situation
my player who you know I'm Lee Norton on
had that in the past with the ever you
know they did hilly was phenomenal for
Northern Ireland spike maybe his club
its club situation not being as healthy
as it could be and that's what we fierce
with Kyle and you know I think it is in
a different situation because he's
played extremely well for us you know
he's a great champion and you know he's
in a situation that's club which he's
not really in control of you know he's
not getting many opportunities either to
be fair I'm it's not as if he's a lot of
opportunities he went six months alone
to Turkey because he wanted to play
games they wanted he wanted to make sure
when the you know the game came around
for us in in march against Finland and
against Romania and Jinnah
you know he's playing first-team
football which he was and we scored two
goals against Finland and he you know he
he actually could have won the game for
us in Romania just at home do remain he
was disappointed he missed a good chance
to go keeping me to good see if but you
know as the develop situation from
because he is so important to us he is
so important us how we play you know it
does give you you know that I let that
we need and you know hopefully as I say
between now and the finals that you know
his club situation improved whether it's
at Norwich or whether it's elsewhere and
then we go on you know we have sex
players in the championship for example
and then the rest of the lads that make
up the squad reader you know as I say
League One League two or the SPL but we
bring the big the biggest I think I
suppose complement to our squatters is
really the there's a really strong
spirit in the squad so it doesn't matter
you know if a player isn't Premier
League and a player who's in league two
there's no difference how they interact
with each other how they respect each
other is very much
you know it's across the board they have
that there's a there's a healthy respect
amongst amongst the group and amongst
the players and you know I think that's
testament to the types of Premier League
players that we have you know we see a
lot of things Premier League players do
a lot of things know that you know can
put people off them but our lads I have
to say our exam
you know and I've been fantastic in
terms of you know height of you know
moolah and belt last parrot within the
squad but you know we asked players to
step up you know if Connor McLaughlin is
the best example of it you know we have
a allowed his planet fleet would tie in
here
you know toiling a little bit in league
one at this moment time but he was
stepping up and you know he played nine
of the ten games that we had in the
campaign and you know he didn't look at
players he held his own he was one of
our best players you know over the piece
of the campaign as well and you know so
I think it's always pleasing when you
find a player or a player comes in and
steps up and and is he not only able to
like you know come into the team and do
well but actually stay on the team and
actually enhance the team and Connor has
done that all over Norwood's obviously
done that established himself as well
Stewart Dallas for example you know a
player now at Leeds but only 18 months
two years ago Stewart I was in Luna at
Northampton from Brentford you know now
he's an established championship player
I think people really see his Worth and
he came international you know Kim and
halfway through the campaign and you
know he gave us that you know boost on
the left-hand side that we need it how
do you try to find additions to that
score are you always with the ancestry
records of players with that yeah we do
a lot you know the Internet's a great
thing you know you can find so much
information about people you know we
have people on the ground we try and
find players but I think the biggest
thing it's not a case of just casting
the net and finding anyone with a
Northern Ireland you know bloodline that
will come and play for us because our
team is essentially boys that are born
in Northern Ireland if you look at our
campaign you know hungry the Hungry game
was a perfect example and we used 14
players 13 of them were born in Northern
Ireland only Oliver Norwood was the one
that wasn't you know Jimmy Ward was
injured that game and probably Jimmy and
all the other to that starting players
I've played the most through the
campaign who have come to us through
eligibility always been in our system
since under-17 for example as well so
yeah I think it's important that you can
you can improve your score of course it
is but equally I think those players are
have to be better than what you have
it's not just a case of taking players
to the sake of it so we keep a close eye
on our all of our players you know we as
a saying tool we probably have a
for a 5 to 50 players and then the four
leagues in England and the top two
leagues in Scotland and you know so we
continue to monitor them all and I
suppose for us the big thing is is that
international football for our players
can enhance their club career and I
think that's important you know so if we
have a Connor McLaughlin displaying for
an ordinarily
give him the opportunity potentially to
play at a higher level and there were
people obviously view him and see is
worth at a higher level so it's a lot of
work you know but equally you know as I
say we have to do that we're not blessed
with a huge resource when you took over
it was in the middle of a period where
there were concerns a lot of players
were choosing to play for the Republic
does that stop now is that still going
on or what have you done to try to
address that well we've done an awful
lot under age level you know when I came
in there wasn't really any structure
there if I'm honest there wasn't a set
underage structure and you know I heard
maybe about a year and haven't looked at
the whole situation you know I brought
Jimmy junkie - performance director and
as a title I was given and basically
we've tried to restructure underage
football in terms of our better players
are underage and I are working with the
Association up to three times four times
a week from and obviously they but their
clubs are with the Association they play
with their clubs and and they represent
and we give them greater exposure at
international level you know so some you
know we have we're not taking kids away
under like what we've called is club and
I would under the club and I umbrella
and we take them away from needs of 10
11 12 which would never have happened in
the past to be honest we put good people
then you know Steven Robinson came in
with me from the start he's obviously
working with seniors cordon I only works
with mother well but like Steven got a
huge amount of work in 17 19 20 ones
Steven Kragen there's no at 19 you know
Jim takes the 20 ones were so we put
people who I felt it was very important
to put players X players and players
but maybe X players that the younger
players could still identify with you
know deal with Healey for example
that a lot of work in club a ni as well
so just to have Deva around and have
young players you know interact with it
was very important as well obviously
before you know it only took a lengthy
job a few weeks back as well so you know
I think what we're trying to do is we
want the young players of Northern
Ireland obviously to play for Northern
Ireland we recognize that they have the
option to go and play for the Republic
of Ireland but we hope that by taking
them from such young is that they wreck
that they have some sort of loyalties
the wrong word but I think an
affiliation say well actually club and I
Northern Ireland played a big part in my
development you know the wrong thing for
me to do now is to go and play for the
Republic of Ireland listen we still have
one or two that have done it and but you
know I anytime any of those situations
has ever risen to be honest I've
addressed it myself you know I've sat
with players you know I've start with
players their parents their agents we
spoke to him says listen I'm not sure
this is the right thing to do I think
asking a young player to change his
international allegiance you know say
between the age of 17 and 21 as a pure
decision by any Association because you
know that player there and has no other
option for the rest of his career and I
think that it's something that should be
looked at because young players make
rash decisions and they make them maybe
emotionally based or whatever it may be
and and and they regret it you know I
know loads of odds that have made that
decision that have regretted it because
you know it didn't turn out to be what
you know they were promised or what they
felt it was gonna be and you know
they're ultimately and I you know
they're Northern Ireland born players
who cannot play for Northern Ireland and
you know I think that that's something
that I think you know has to be
addressed at the higher levels of the
game that if it comes at senior and I
still level that's fine but don't be
asking a young player to change his
allegiance what you know what between 17
and 21 it might be understandable for
their lives if they've grown up in in a
family or a community who identify and
support the other team and all the know
um it's very difficult for them to be
with their peers and totally yeah I mean
I I have never criticized any any player
that's done that you know I I when I
took the job James McLaren was in the
process of going through what's called
the international transfer and
I played the top teams right you know
and and and Jim's old and he stuck to
his decision which is fine you know I've
seen GM sense and we speak and there's
no animosity there for me and any part
you know that's nice to see him do well
I was at the game yesterday West
Bromwich Albion he's got to be a header
so I don't I don't I would never
criticize a player for that at all I
understand that you know I've grown up
in Northern Ireland you know I grew up
in a Catholic family myself so I totally
understand you know that side of things
but you know this this team like why
will says and the whole time I ever
played for an online we always had agree
at maxim's ward there was never an issue
there was never a religious issue
amongst the players at all there was
some times when I would see the
atmosphere in the stadium could have
been better you know I don't think
anyone will ever you know hide behind
that and but the IFA have done a
fantastic job and you know in changing
that I think the atmosphere at the
National Stadium one's a partner is
fantastic you know and is totally for
both sides the community in our team
represents both sides of the community
and you know lonely that continue that's
what you know when we when it came in
that's what we wanted to build and
hopefully you know you know I think the
biggest thing for myself and Jem and the
lads at work Steven creating Steven
Robinson is that any young player who's
born in Northern Ireland aspires to play
for Northern Ireland and that's kind of
what we're hoping to create you
mentioned your own background in those
negotiations with some people do you
think possibly yeah I don't know
possibly it has you know I mean I think
that maybe people look at it slightly
definitely I can't you know and I
suppose I'm not the best person to
answer that really but certainly you
know we have a very you know open I'd
like to analyze a Jim's done a huge
amount of work that way and you know as
I say we just want to bring lads both
sides the community they're training
three nights four nights a week together
we're bringing lads from Derry and aloud
from Belfast lads from all over the
country bringing together they're
working on a regular basis of the best
players in the country and ultimately
you know like you know as I always say
our young players that they're never
that far away you know I I first worked
with you know I took the job I'd I first
worked in our excellence program with
with Liam Donnelly who's a young player
of Fulham on a
an astroturf pets and Cookstown and
three years later I put them on against
chili and a senior in the national so
you know I I want our young players to
recognize that you know because of our
resource the opportunity to play
international football is both Northern
Ireland there's no Tiger with that and I
will always be there like you know our
numbers are nowhere near the extent of a
little public of Ireland you know I
think the Republic have over fifty
players in the championship alone for
example so that gives you an indication
so you know there's a there's a there's
a thought process that has to go into it
for a player and their representative
stable actually if you want you know and
Northern Ireland well represent the best
opportunity if you play under national
football you know I think we have the
capability to deal with with one or two
retire holes but ultimately our squad
will be weaker and we may not have the
resource to back things up off we have
injury or suspension so you know I've
enjoyed the job for four years I've
always said that you know if continuing
the job that you know I'll continue to
do the way I have Donna and you know one
thing that footballs taught me I haven't
played for 13 or 14 clubs it's you know
it's dangerous to look too far ahead
particularly as a manager so you know if
I get that you know if I continue in the
role which which is where my focus is at
the minute you know I'll continue to do
it but equally you know if a club
situation arises I think you know as a
manager you always have to look at that
and as I say it's a case of but for me
as I say the main focus is purely on
France